uh you turned around and ended up
drawing
and it seems like arena had that same
bug in her game she was completely
winning
in her game against knee uh what do you
what are your evaluation
of this position it seems like things
have really turned against the five-time
champ sure
i mean and anything can happen um
victoria has been playing pretty well
the second half of the tournament
so you know i'm rooting for her i'm also
rooting for tatev
at this point i think a playoff is very
likely tomorrow
indeed so this position what about this
game this is a shocker to us
uh but it looks like a fight used to be
that
zatonski was better then all of a sudden
she was worse
looks like now she's evened out the game
because she's gonna somehow win this
pawn
are you surprised by this turn of events
at the championships didn't look like
abrahamian had a chance and they had two
champions nine time champions between
them in
in zatonski and crush and now they're
not winning the last game when it
counted
yeah well i mean with these sorts of
events um you
you never know what will happen and
tatev was always you know at the top you
know of course
ever there was a lot of buzz between
crush and tonski but she was always up
there so
it comes as no surprise to me that you
know she has a really good shot here
so your tournament is over uh what do
you do now in the next several months
um yeah you know it's back to the real
world when you're playing in a
tournament
especially one like this um like the
entire tournament consumes your life and
i know
every chess player will be able to
relate to the feeling that you know
nothing exists except your routine in
the tournament
and you know i've been avoiding the
emails i've been getting about what i
need to do to register for the bar
and everything so now i have to make
sure that everything is in order there
i'm playing chicago open next so in a
few days so
yeah while i'm in chess mode we'll see
how that goes and what else
follows that yeah well chicago open then
i take my bar prep courses
take the bar july 30th and then i have
two and a half months off to
travel maybe i'll play in tournaments in
europe you know train for millionaire
chess of course
indeed of course i have to get you to
say that on i knew it was kind of thing
yeah all right well thanks so much we
enjoyed watching your enterprising play
of the championships and we wish you
the best of luck in your chess career
and of course with the bar okay thanks
so much maurice
fm alyssa malagina after a good victory
to close out the championship ending up
in the top half
of the tournament career woman and chess
player
not a bad combo entrepreneur yeah that's
right
something huh i've got to go to our uh
key game of the round between the two
leaders
ocobian and and
alex we've just seen this last move
f we will go back to this position
it was the move rook c5 by the way
they kept letterman in the game
i thought that he was actually seriously
worse rook c5
i thought that white had to play a move
like rook
down to get behind the pawns but
this pawn is really really fast rooksy
five very good move rookie six
king back rook attacks uh
the b pawn rook a5 rook takes rook takes
um f5 now by var
and still i like black's activity really
a lot
i think you know you want to play for a
win
but you can overdo it very easily uh
here
far's down to three minutes on the clock
though for what it's worth okay
again the practical election yeah
well i mean just to just to give an
example of
how things could really go wrong for
white if you go rook a5 and you go pawn
hunting over here
well e2 rook check king here and guess
what
there's a sudden queen about to make an
apparent
appearance in the position i don't say
it's a dead win or anything like that
um white has possibilities of fortresses
but the uh tide would sure have turned
if black is able to promote
meanwhile i thought you were also going
to take us to the kamsky for delegation
because that game looks crazy
oh there were a lot of sacrifices in
that game right
but um again so in this position uh
lenderman to play and um
this one is still very hard to call i
think lenderman
should should ease back on the throttle
a bit
and start thinking maybe i should draw
this game because
it could easily go wrong he's still
pressing for the win he has played the
move
a5 and a version of kobe and of course
uh
down to three minutes on the clock snuck
in a stair though as he
hovers over well king king
his king to play king e3 and he hasn't
played it instead he played i thought he
was hovering over his cape
it was his rook he played work to a4
instead rook to a4 so he got behind the
pawn
okay i and now also menacing at rook a2
jack
uh going over here to snabble upon over
here as well
snabble did you just make up that word i
know my wife do that she likes novels
give credit where credit's due
i know she is the originator so still
all the play for i think all three
results are possible still
in this game between lenderman nacobian
perhaps lenderman has had the upper hand
most of the way but it's very easy to
overplay his hand here
and i think var is feeling very
confident despite
the big disadvantage he has on the clock
and looks like it's some messy stuff
going on and got a camp schedule oh yeah
so let's back up a few moves there okay
so
i we were more or less around
uh these parts and i thought that uh
gotta had the better of it gotta play
bishop to g4
activating his bishop first before
playing the move
f2 f3 you wanted to make sure he had an
active bishop
a3 pass pawns must be pushed and all
that
uh c 4 c5 attacking the bishop
a2 just ignoring the pawn takes d6
thread perhaps
wow it's like queen b there's a queen b1
in the position
exactly you can't take the bishop queen
d1 queen b1 threatening
uh just in a one equals queen and the
move rooks you won which would
ordinarily save remember that fischer
position we did that earlier where
rushevsky missed the idea queen b4 to e1
right well in this case rook c1 um
is insufficient because of queen takes
e4 precisely
so uh so just b a1 equals queen where
queen takes f1
both in the position to which gotta
played f2
f3 protecting his queen uh
in so that he could meet a move like
queen b1 with the move rook c1 which is
what he wanted to do
and after f2 f3 bishop
dropped back to b8 and
bang rook takes a2 and it looks like god
has just
got a pawn god has got us god has got a
pawn
and that's a huge pawn by the way
because that was
going to be the source of of black's
counter play
and i can see white's rook sweeping into
the position
with rook b1 and rook a8 and
gotta kamsky looking gr the defending
champion
playing his best chess uh for the final
game
final round here in round 11 of the us
championships he looks
this is the god of kamsky that we knew
and expected
uh when he came here to defend his his
championship
undefeated throughout the tournament and
looking very
very good f3 a really cool move i love
it
just simple chess right hey f3 has been
kind of a big move today right
you mentioned f3 earlier a similar quiet
move right um that didn't turn out quite
as amazing but meanwhile so got a kamsky
really on top
meanwhile what's going on in our crucial
game for the women's championship
between
me and crush as it looks like zatonski
might be headed to a draw
the only way we don't see a play-off is
if irena crash wins this game
right and she has played the move rook
e3
and victoria i actually thought that
victoria had the
upper hand here she could probably go
into a drawn rook and pawn end game by
simply taking
and doing something like season 5 she's
thinking about winning oh i i i just
sometimes i have my doubts
marie sassy what do you think uh it's
all
victoria no draw forget that she has a
great position
there's no reason to accept the draw in
this position because it's
her advantage right now particularly
after the last move
by irina crush in this position irina
played the move rook to e3
i'll just point out a nice little
variation if she had played rook to e2
that looks kind of natural right
wrong knight to h3 check and after any
king move let's go
to let's go to f6 for example now the
move
knight to f4 and oops you just dropped
an exchange
and the game this game is now over past
pawn rook this guy's going to fall
the game is all for white
instead after 92 she played rook to e3
and now
the computer is saying rook to d8 start
thinking about pushing this guy home
this rook can't get behind the pawn so
what happens if this advance happens
she always has any traits she wants this
is completely under control
nothing here no improvement is possible
if you try to move rook to f3
then simply rook g2 and what can you do
your position's
semi-stuck you might have to back your
king up out of there and allow this pawn
to go forward maybe even allow a king
move
still not a win by any stretch
but the person with the advantage right
now is white
she should just play a couple of solid
moves and the pressure will be
on arena to hold this game we should
note however
that irina does have 13 minutes on her
clock to her opponent's five minutes
and that's going to be the critical
point if victoria is going to go for the
win she's going to have to go for it
in time pressure so looks like you were
right jen
they are going to end up in some kind of
time pressure at least victoria is
it's up to irina to keep a nice lead on
the clock keep that padding because
she's definitely worse here fighting for
her life here at the u.s women's
championships
that's right although you gotta wonder
victoria remember she took a draw
against tatev abrahamian when she was up
to
pawn so i'm wondering how much is she
thinking i'm playing a grand master that
highest rated player in the tournament
it'd be cool to get a draw from that
dangerous position earlier
and how much is she thinking i'm going
to win this game i have no idea
no and at the moment i agree it's a
confidence thing
but if victoria continues to play well
um arena is in trouble
she just has to find these moves real
quick
he played work f8 instead rook to f8
okay so that's a little bit more of a
defensive
move but still not bad i mean rook f8
is basically saying you can't i get
oh i guess you could actually play king
f4
um but in any case rook f8
i don't see exactly how arena is going
to make progress on
on the king side maurice is saying
everything is is
is blocked up yes that's a good move
and that has a nasty little trick
associated with it check this out
yeah king f4 your move very natural
looking move to be sure
sure runs into d6 oops suddenly you
can't take this pawn
because your bishop is hanging right
with check
and what just happened you lost the
piece he lost a piece
for no reason so rook f8 is controlling
the position
black's best move the is it seems like
it's king to eight six
not very attractive move right now and
then the rook if it wants to if she
decides she can move her rook over to c8
look at that threat rook to c6 you know
the big problem here is this bishop is
not in play
this bishop is frozen and only protected
nothing is happening on this side
for black and white in the meantime can
start generating threats on the other
side of the board rook c6
is a tough plan i mean if the rook if
this pawn becomes a
it comes on a pawn on c6 that's going to
be serious
and even if she trades here she can
start thinking about this pawn
getting these guys down the board this
position is tricky but she still has to
find the moves she still has to find the
moves
let's see what happens in the next three
moves well we're definitely going to
keep our eyes closely on this one um
it's amazing that
there's only five games left in the
championship and four of them are
decisive games for
the playoffs and the championships good
job guys
shout out to the players wow the other
one is robson ownership which we
we won't look at because we just have to
keep our eyes peeled on these
crucial games are going to determine our
tournament winners
by the way before we we we
as we get a chance and then things are
heating up a big shout out to everybody
yourself
maurice all the people at the st louis
chess club tony joy bray
alex marler the carol jurecki the chief
arbiter
the staff of lesters is the staff at the
hall of fame
our sponsors rex and uh
thank you all and of course our our
audience uh we do it for you yeah it's
been a lot of fun
and we hope that you will remember to
join us for the entirety of the
zinfandel but
yeah as you were saying that closing
made it sound like you were thinking you
were going to get out of work no no
no no no no i want to come back
impossible i remain on at the both lose
and um
and we could just have two champions
that's true the chances are probably
like less than one percent though
yeah i'm kind of looking forward to a
playoff i'm already excited about a
playoff actually
i'm saying there is a chance okay okay
um not a high one though so how about
anna zakowski
okay well first of all she has captured
that a pawn that she was going after and
that variation that you pointed out but
meanwhile
katarina's pawns going pretty fast okay
i just
was looking at the lenderman game
nothing has happened since the
last move rook a6 so alex lenderman on
move
uh i'm bringing up the zatonski game now
knight takes look at that four versus
two majority
on the king side past apon over here
i'm just going to say boldly state the
obvious i think white
is in time to draw also because this
pawn
is so this apon is so um
how do you say on the edge of the board
right after a situation like this
one of black's pieces yes thank you so
much thank you so very much
uh one of black's pieces is going to be
tied down
to keeping that a-pawn under control in
the meanwhile
black won't have enough uh to force her
for versus two majority keep our king
over there we need to make sure not to
stretch our king away and fall into
something like g4 with the idea
takes on g4 and f3 yeah what happened
at the pawn breakthrough so i'm looking
at a draw in this game
uh much more opportunity i think
for uh something good or bad to happen
depending upon your foreign view in the
crush game
agreed and so you think it's much more
likely to have a decisive result in that
game one way or the other
one way or the other and even though
objectively speaking arena should be
playing for a draw
i'm sure she's hoping hoping hoping
counting on a mistake by victoria
because that's right she is she is
spending a lot of time
at this moment she's kind of getting
down remember she started this move with
15 minutes
three times as much time as victoria and
now she's creeping down
to equalizing the time situation wow
actually guys
right now i'm looking at the computer's
options and it's saying
there's only one move for black that's
it everything else loses
which is incredible to think about right
now because you know irina is thinking
what can i do here what can i do the
problem is
this cluster it's just nasty you've got
to figure out a way to unravel
so the move k6 is actually the only move
anything else is failure anything else
creates a horrible position for you
and you need to make sure you don't fall
into some
nasty tricks a move like king h4 for
example you know that looks kind of a
normal move but
after rook check the king has to go back
suddenly this knight check you can't
touch it
because the rook is protecting a nasty
pin the king goes
and now another night move and where did
this knight come from it's
in the game attacking everything this
rook is under control you try to drop
back
pawn up to d6 this threat of knight to
d5 suddenly
is on the board and what are you
supposed to do to keep the game going
here knight goes in very powerful
position now it's not easy to calculate
any of this
i mean this just it's not clear who's
winning who might be
be losing what what is the situation
here very tough
for black however to make the right
moves this b-pawn is about to drop this
d-pawn is quite strong the king is
exposed the rook's under
attack bishop is still pinned so what is
she going to do
she's in a very nasty situation let's
see if we if she has finally moved the
worst part is
that her time situation is so bad
and that took a while to push and she
has
she has found the only move of
all the moves that keep her in the game
kudos to her as a gm
showing her strength she found the only
move in the position
king to h6 to try to bring the king back
this doesn't mean anything though she's
still
much worse and you know how hard it is
to go from
easily winning to okay it's equal
to oh my goodness i am probably
losing this position that is hard to
control
your internal swings but she is a
practical player she's been around the
block she knows
her opponent is still going to have to
find the moves and it looks as though
victoria knee is trying to stay solid in
the position she's playing to move rook
to f7 which
is frowned upon by the computer in this
position this is
not the optimal move not making any
progress showing that she just wants to
be
somewhat defensive with her move she
needs to be aggressive here
swing her rook over but now keeping her
rook there she's thinking this pawn is
dangerous
let me control it the clock times guys 4
48
it seems for me at least on my board
here
six minutes for crush harder to play
though for the black
pieces so she's gonna have to be very
careful guys
agreed i mean the night is always a
little bit more fun to play with in time
pressure but i don't i just don't think
again i don't think me is playing for a
win i think she's thinking like oh be
qualified
of course if if a trick presents itself
she's going to pounce but
i don't think she's thinking in her head
i'm better and i'm going to crush crush
absolutely rook f7 is indicative of that
rook c8 as maurice pointed out playing
rook c6 that's
an obvious statement i'm playing for a
win rook f7
is kind of a statement i'm playing for a
draw maurice guys we know something that
irina crush
may or may not know though hashi looked
at the game between
zatonski uh and nemkova
probably not because if she hasn't if
she's been rooted to the board
she might be thinking joy's not enough i
have to play for a win when in fact a
draw would be
more than enough right now for her to go
into a playoffs and if she starts
playing for a win
she might blow the game end up losing so
i imagine she must
have at least glad over to glance
at that result you know what happened
over there i think
we can expect that she must have done
that so that she could come to the board
and know what is needed
in this competitive situation i think
that all depends on whether or not you
got up on room 40 to get a drink of
water or something because even at that
point it was clear that datonski was not
winning her game
exactly so if she did that then she's in
fine shape but after
she after it moved 40 she sunk right
back into the game and she's just in his
own
and for the most part in this position
it's all about finding good moves i
don't think
i don't think she has a moment yet where
it's uh like some force drawn she has to
reject it
if you may take a look at the club she
has less time
again than victoria for the first time
right in the game well actually
for the second time yes but the first
time in this time control and we saw
that when that happened in last time
control
you got to credit crush when she does
get into time pressure at least you can
say it's logical because it usually
means she's in some trouble
so some of the other players seem to get
into gratuitous time pressure irena on
the other hand
it seems like she's got a reason
although of course i know how you feel
about the one second countdown
and she hasn't gotten that close um in
this game
we have gotten some great comments from
our listeners um in different languages
we welcome you all over the world
watching these games um daniel ranch
says
could this be a repeat of carlson
kramnik at candidates 2013
we're both crush and zatonski lose
backing into the tie for first
i don't think that's gonna happen but
it's amazing that we're even close to
that because
compared to the candidates where even if
the favorites lost
everyone is more tightly packed here
we're dealing with players which are a
couple hundred points higher rated
right so we never could have expected
that and by the way
tatiaf has already won so in case both
players lose we have a new u.s champion
in tatia
they can't back the way uh they could
back their way into a playoff with
draws at peace by the way i just took a
quick glance of the game
of god of kamski's he's dominating yes
he's going to win
he's going to win 100 i think that f3
move was a very pretty idea you know
fidel had all the tactics worked out but
missed the quiet move right
so it covered everything on the d4 uh
pawn and we've got a comment coming in
in russian so i popped it into google
translate i did study russian for like a
couple semesters in college but it was
insufficient
and it says in the us chess champs
broadcast the commentators have chess
level
and own profession presenter the
combination which we do not have
i love that translation
it sounds like a compromise yeah it does
sound like a compliment the combination
which we do not have
google could juice up that translation
of it to say you know
a little bit more it says my own
profession presenter i like that
okay very nice very i think they're
trying to say that we're professional
and we don't
suck at chess also thank you
not completely not completely but very
okay what has happened after rook f7
don't tell me that
uh arena has gone into a deep no she
hasn't she played work to e2 actually
after work to f7
so rook e2 has been and now victoria and
he going under
under about to be under three minutes on
the clock
oh my so dangerous situation for
victoria and i think that's why tatev
was not so confident
you know of course she didn't want to
jinx herself if that actually exists so
she didn't want to say yeah this game's
definitely not going to be a win for
irena but
but doesn't rookie 2 encourage the move
knight d3
uh bringing the knight the f4 square is
the juicy square because of course that
not that's forking two rooks and don't
forget that that rook on g6
is critical to the defense of the pawn
on b6
so if arena decided that she wanted to
trade rooks
she probably wouldn't be happy with the
result
which would mean the loss of her b6 pawn
as well as
the double threat of knight f4 check so
uh
knight d3 is screaming to be played
automatic what is she doing she's
thinking about taking
taking on g4 i agree with you because
that's
crazy in time pressure and she's in time
pressure people like to go for trade so
hopefully she'll make the right decision
and she'll play well not hopefully for
irena but um
it's really interesting we see this
tradition comes into play
when you don't have a lot of time in the
clock not only then jen
uh in in a lot of positions just to
simplify
but it's crazy that she's taking her
time in this moment when knight d3 is
just sitting on the board in fact
the only move to stop knight f4 is is uh
either king back to g5 or or in rook
rook back to e4
and she has played knight takes g4 and i
was going to say the more time she
thinks the more likely she is just going
to play this simplifying line
and as joshua points out after after f
takes g4
which has been played you're predicting
d6 to make uh to force more trades
well exactly i mean victoria obviously
it's a confidence issue
she feels like she's up against a
stronger rated player she doesn't want
to lose
and so she she played a simplifying line
really wrong oh my god i have some news
what happened is this right
answers okay um we have to confirm a
result here but
maybe we can get the webcam on lender
minicobian because i'm hearing that
there is actually a result in this game
let's see is there actually a result in
this game it looks like var has won
it says that barr has won on
uschestchamps.com let's
confirm that because that doesn't look
like it it should be the case
how is that possible so we need to find
out i think maybe there's an error there
definitely but we're going to find that
out in a second and confirm that this
game actually has been a draw
which seems much more likely
so those of you watching on
uschesschamps.com hold your horses
it doesn't seem like ferocious cobian
has won and it has been switched to a
draw this game is a draw
a kobe and lender in have drawn the game
i mean the only way for that to have
happened would be if lederman lost on
time and he was ahead of the clock
in the entire game and still was and he
would have to hang some funny business
mate which wow which is actually which
is which is actually possible
here come to think of it well whose move
is it or it's bl it's all white
white would have had to do this and then
black do this
and then that and then get mated and
then we say okay that's
completely ridiculous but otherwise come
on
we know no way in the world lenderman's
going to let that happen okay obviously
repetition so now they have a draw
we're in playoff mode folks yeah in fact
it looks like we're going to have that
three-way play-off
as well we've gotta probably winning his
game
and tie breaks rule the day from him he
will exceed himself into the finals
despite the fact
that when you look at the tournament it
feels like version or lender and
should have the better time more
deserving or whatever but i
they were leading the tournament more
often but in that direct encounter gotta
kamsky has more points
did i call it or what i was the guy who
said that uh
in case uh of a draw and in case kamsky
won
that my money was on what do you want a
chicken wing yeah
oh i want two
everybody's money is on kamsky now look
at this final setup
ocobian and lenderman now have to go to
an armageddon match they were
firmly in the lead now they have to limp
out of that match
hoping just to to qualify to play
against komski
that's just that's just gimme for kamsky
that's like him sitting back saying
please just suffer
so when you come to me i'm going to get
my hands on you
so yeah komski for choice if he wins
this game no question about it
it's going to be rough on the other
players that's right it's actually
interesting it looks i mean look at this
last move he played d5 i mean it's
totally over it looks like he's going to
win this game
totally overwhelming i'm afraid and so
this is he's material ahead
two bishops so this one's g5 discovers
the rook on a7 so that should force the
move rook takes a1
and now we can't we can't sneak into
discovery but just after rook takes a
one
guess what that pawn on c7 is simply
massive
uh if you play he takes d5 queen takes
d5 c takes d5
this bishop covering that square moved
like bishop b6 followed by c7 i've seen
the two bishops before in this
tournament haven't we
right and now even knight e6 trying to
plug the square isn't working
because you can just take it and then
play c7 and we're
and we're threatening actually we're
threatening to play
both oh we're both centering c takes b8
and c8 equals right
but okay another way another way to win
a piece yeah
either way and one thing i'm going to be
really curious to hear
about lenderman is if he knew about this
tie break situation or not so we're
going to find out that soon
we've got grandmaster alexander
lenderman securing at least a tie for
well securing a tie for with between
either two players or three players
for first here at the u.s championship
and guaranteeing him
a playoff match tomorrow correct
and we're with grandmaster alexander
lindeman after his draw
critical draw in the last round against
uh cobian
alex welcome to the show first of all we
saw you pressing
did you decline a draw offer in the game
at one point at one point i did yeah
actually i moved 30. on move 30 why did
you decline right at that moment it
looked kind of even-ish that position
yeah but
you know i feel like i have to do my
maximum to try to do something
and that's how magnus carlsen plays so i
try to take example from the best
you needed to push in this game now the
result is a draw
and it seems that you will with komski
winning his game
have to go into a playoffs did you
realize that you would have to play a
kobian
in the playoffs just to qualify to play
against kamsky
no i had no idea i just went in there
and battled and uh
you know it's okay it is what it is what
do you feel about your chances there you
have to play kobe and again in an
armageddon game
uh with its own crazy rules of bidding
for time
i have no idea how it works because i
didn't exactly plan on drawing this game
i
but uh now i'll have to find out what it
is and uh
and uh and prepare for it are you
disappointed with the results
uh well uh maybe a little bit but i did
my best i
i really did my best i might have missed
some opportunities i might have been
better at some point but
he it looks like he's in great form he
played
really well it seemed to me i don't know
what the computer says but
i did the best i could and uh but just
couldn't quite do it
well thanks then for joining us and we
wish you good luck you better go find
out those rules
thank you real quickly best of luck in
your
final uh matchups coming up thank you
grandmaster lindemann
who will play it seems a armageddon game
an armageddon game
against okobian to try to qualify to
play against godakomsky
for the u.s title guys yeah and
interestingly this armageddon game if
alex you want to stay for a second you
can hear what it is
it's going to be a rapid armageddon game
45 minutes each on the clock
and you bid for how much time you're
willing to sacrifice in order to get
black and draw odds
so previous bids we've had some
something like like 20
29 minutes i believe things around that
area 20 minutes
i believe that in last year's u.s
championship alejandro ramirez
did like 20 minutes and got a bit 20
minutes 19 seconds or something like
that
they were really really really close and
then the idea of course
is that black has draw odds white has to
win
right exactly so that should be
interesting there's still an increment
in that game as well
five second increment okay so which and
we'll confirm all that later as
as we now we know that we're gonna have
an armageddon game right because it's a
three-way tie
exactly so we must have an armageddon
and let me just shout out to alex that i
really want to congratulate him on his
fantastic success
regardless of what very very much so
very inspiring
uh he was the most decisive player in
the tournament
he had lots of wins he had some draws
but
as he said uh he looks at magnus carlsen
for inspiration
and he says i want to be like magnus i
love it
magnus carlson at the sink field cup
inspiring the results of the us chess
championship at the same location
just five months later exactly gotta
love it so shout out to magnus and
we'll be back in august 26th for this
thing field cup
maurice what's going on in knee crash
big news crush has made some errors and
now she is much worse
maybe losing look at this position a
huge position for white big
initiative that she's created because of
this advance
to the d6 square crush has had to go on
the defensive
to try to save herself against his pawn
advance
and now the move d7 will be quite strong
in this position
and crush on the defensive suddenly it
looks as though she
might be able to play this move but look
at this trick check
move your king over and boom thank you
very much
for your rook and suddenly a problem has
occurred because as she goes for this
pawn
king down and she can't touch the pawn
because this king and pawn ending
is dead lost for her so crush
in a bunch of trouble right now she
might even be losing the game
she has she ticked to under a minute on
the clock
victoria knee with a big not that big a
time advantage but
a time advantage but what's going to
happen who knows
but it looks as though the five-time
champ is in a lot of trouble
guys a heart-stopping game victorian he
doesn't have a lot of time actually
she's ticking down to less than a minute
now
irina cross desperately to move work to
the e8
did she play rook d to d yeah
and that is a sweet sweet trick that
maurice just showed
d7 what could be more natural than the
move rook g7
and it walks into that haymaker rook h1
rook g4
that's an easy easy tactic uh to fall
into as well as to miss
again i think victoria's been trying to
draw this game so she may be thinking
after d7 rook g7
i'll just move my king up and we'll end
up you know
swapping a rook for a pawn each and i'll
make my draw
and she has played c5 again that kind of
move that we've seen a lot from her
going for the trades instead of uh
finding her winning chances uh c5
and getting down to 13 seconds before
she made the movie unbelievable
so after takes on c arena should be
absolutely elated that she gets to trade
is in the balance and she's got almost
less
she's got about a minute left on her
clock right now it's all about instinct
right and nerves nerves
live is definitely just a draw that was
not a good
choice at all by her right right
and b takes e5 what a relief it must be
for arena crush
to get rid of that pawn weakness and
trade it off now she's probably thinking
okay i'm in a four-rook ending not much
i can do
i'm going to try to try to
escort my g-pawn down the board
and bla white is going to escort her
d-pawn down the board
and arena's probably thinking that
uh it's going to be a draw and how about
zatanski namkova these players both have
a lot of time left on the clock
comparison five minutes to three minutes
and by the way we've got an official
result got a camp he has defeated josh
riddell
three-way tie at the top of the u.s
chess championship
got it kamsky we're gonna have not only
we're gonna have a playoff tomorrow we
are gonna have a long playoff so get
ready
guys strap in it could be five or six
hours um
playoff tomorrow um
they're gonna have to prepare a lot of
chicken wings for you yeah
did we did we negotiate like overtime
pay and
maurice you're my agent in such matters
uh
time pay comes not only you get chicken
wings you also get sushi
there you go yes
i'm filing a protest not only are we
going to get a three-way playoff on the
men's side we're gonna get
at least a two-way no it's going to be a
freeway
on the women's side as well after that
last move uh
in the knee game the crush game
three-way playoff both ways
but who has the better tiebreak on the
women's side right we forgot to check
that i should because irina won her game
against tatev and anna
yeah yeah so she clearly so irina will
be sitting pretty waiting
for the other two players and guess what
the two players with the advantage of
the tie break
there are winners from last year so
they're the defending champions they get
to sit back and smile
while the other two players suffer and
think about what they're going to do to
make the winner suffer some more
the only disadvantage there is that
irena
doesn't get to prepare
she doesn't know who she's going to play
whereas both anna
and tatev know to prepare for two people
that makes notice really a silver lining
congratulations
that was remarkable jen i love it i mean
there's two sides to every argument
there you have it not really that
actually made no sense at all but it was
good
hey you forgot outside past quahog
that's what happened when you had
analyzed it right it's the 11th round
for a couple of slips i've had one or
two myself
okay but i was actually thinking that i
was thinking i was like oh yeah they
know who they're gonna play and then
they only have to prepare for two people
and then irena has to only prepare for
two people
wow pretty cool uh zatonski it's all
right
do we have a reason we'll get it
together because it really looks like
it's heading to a result
right here right now uh the breakthrough
on the king side has come with g4
i think anna has prepared now to play
knight
b4 to d3 and to deal with
the oops knight d3
takes and to be able to prepare to deal
with these past
h pawns black will come over here
collect the pawn on
a4 but anna is securing the draw
i actually took the pawn because her
knight can get back in time anyway oh
wonderful
and irena crush and victoria are about
to shake hands we've got
we've got a game that i think we've seen
in another game just
pawn versus rook it's totally over in
fact they're about to play the king
versus king because they want to show
their fighting spirit
we like that okay let's see so
this is what we have seen king takes
rook
on d6 pawn g3 will come king e5 will
come king
h2 and rook takes king takes and a
hearty hand class
for a very very hard-fought dramatic
final round and arena must be thinking
darn i'd beat my closest rival anna
zatonski i had the tournament in my
hands
now i've got a play off but on the other
hand when she
reviews this game she'll probably think
to herself
wow i was really lucky uh things could
have really gone wrong at victoria
i can't imagine that yes remember her
position from the opening
she was completely winning like
completely it was crushing
the king was on d2 sitting there waiting
to be
shredded she's going to be disgusted
with herself there's no
she's and the way she is she's very hard
on herself and not finding the right
moves she's going to be disgusted with
herself
even though she should have lost later
she's not going to say yeah look
she's going to be disgusted because she
was winning and then she's going to be
disgusted because she allowed herself to
be losing
and now she has to fight tomorrow but
reality's reality on the chess board
right
okay well and they are going to play
we're going to continue playing king
verse king for a few moves it looks like
queen first thinking about the position
for a moment
well you saw that arena had uh
put the k put her queen she made a queen
yes
and there they go the the game has been
drawn wow
arena crushing victoria uni irena crush
and tateva verhami are now tied for
first in the u.s women's chess
championship
i'm sorry with anna zatonski are ready
to catch up will they be joined
by um ana zatanski so we have this
position
by anna now it's namkova to play i
believe
and she will likely play the move knight
b2
attacking white's knight hoping
to promote the pawn obviously you can't
take the knight you'll have to play
knight f2
then knight takes knight takes and
all black has to do is bring her knight
over
uh to the queen king side to
sacrifice the knight instead she played
h2 first but
just to move h2 just move order
difference knight f2 knight b2
threatening knight d3 jack i'm sorry
what what so she played h2 instead
instantly and then after knight f2
knight to b2 is also a double attack on
a4
and threatening knight to d3 i see sorry
so that forces me to drop back with the
king
knight takes king takes now it's much
easier
for me to bring over my knight to
sacrifice it for the
pawn so and we have seen that on the
board knight b2
on the board king g3 and we also have
defending champion goddakanski and i
wonder what he knew about the tie break
rule somebody must have checked them
before right
there's an angel over goddess uh
shoulders in this championship he'll
tell us who she is
indeed we are with the raiding champ
four-time champion
godakomski after a strong
powerful victory in his game against
josh friedel
gotta welcome to the show it's gotta
feel good that
you actually are still in it yeah i was
pretty surprised because um
the game went like up and down a lot
and i got really lucky at the end in a
way lucky it looks like you played
some powerful moves and just pushed your
opponent off the board not really
my bishop dark swedish was out of the
game
most of the game and then i just got
lucky when
he managed to allow me the construction
of putting the queen on a4 bishop on g4
and then white is
better after that i was completely calm
of course
oh so nervous going into the game were
you watching the game between
kobien and and lenderman keeping an eye
on the proceedings during the game
sure i was keeping an eye that kind of
made me a little bit thinking about
other things
other than the game but um overall um
i'm glad that i didn't make any blunders
this time okay
so now you're tied for first which has
been a while in coming
you've caught them at the end uh do you
know the tie break rules
uh well according to the tie break rules
carol just explained to me that
since i have a best tie break because i
had direct win against
lenderman that means that jacobian
lenderman will be playing against each
other first
and then i'll have to play the winner
for the title did you know that before
she told you
no okay because lenderman didn't know it
either you guys just put your head down
and
and play chess so this is a good
situation for you what do you feel are
your chances going into the tiebreak day
they just became much better so
yeah see you crack a smile for the first
time here i mean it's got to be tough on
those guys you've played in the
armageddon
before armageddon game any suggestions
to them as to what the bid the best bid
might be for
for these two players well every time
it's like a first time so
there is no no way to explain things
unless you actually play them
so it's going to be really exciting
playoffs and judging by what i
have just seen in women's uh games seems
to be coming to the playoffs as well so
this can be a really exciting day
tomorrow
it's never happened before at the u.s
championships this kind of
playoff system will you be watching the
game between a kobe and
linderman i don't know yet i don't know
of course okay all right well we wish
you luck in
your games and see you tomorrow
absolutely
four-time champ godakomski did what he
had to do
and now he's all set in a sweet position
for the playoffs tomorrow
guys thank you maurice i i consider
uh one of the world-class
rapid chess players and so that was why
i'm making him
and everybody else here seems to be
making him such a clear favorite
in uh the situation but wow
um he didn't godda will be the first to
tell you he didn't impress
uh either himself or any of us but
he did what he had to do which was win
a crucial game which is the same thing
that arena had to do when she
faced anna and that's why they're the
defending champions and why they're the
champions in the first place
i i've always said that people who win
in must-win situations are the people
who win the championships
right it's that simple and yet guys
we had two big champions in arena and
anna and they had to win
to to win the championship and they
faltered the critical moment and it was
abrahamian who had to win
just like gada did
in fact abrahamian's path is so much
more unlikely we were chatting about it
that this was possible
so much more unlikely because anna and
irina did not play each other in the
last round so it wasn't
one draw that pre that produced the two
results so to speak
both the kobe with the half and
linderman with a half
she needed two draws to happen to have a
chance
and her two opponents were playing
players much lower down on the rating
scale
what are the odds of this particular
result of course the odds are worse to
see two zeros and she winning
her winning the championship but the
odds of this results are also
pretty low i mean i would have given
this i don't know 25
maybe something like that happening the
two draws but ana
ana didn't win irina didn't win and i
mean anna's still playing but we suspect
this is
an easy draw and that means that tatev
by winning her game in dominant fashion
at the end
she's got a chance to win it all i mean
that's uh that's a pretty
impressive place to be of course tall
order because guess what she's got anna
again
and then she has to play against arena
and that's not going to be easy but if
you're going to become the u.s champion
might as well beat the woman who's
four-time champ and the woman who's
five-time champ
to prove yourself at the tape guys well
this will be
pretty fascinating to to recap it's how
45 minute armageddon game is gonna
start both three-player matches right
so we're going to see ana and tatev play
a 45-minute game
armageddon game no increment or delay as
far as i know
right and they're going to bid to see
who will get the black and the draw lots
in the past we've had a five second
increment in that game so without it
the bids are going to be higher right
you can't bid as low as 20 minutes if
there's no increment that's great
right so you're pretty good at game
theory
you've got to imagine yourself in the
situation you want to
play black and to take the draw odds i
suppose
how low would you bid would you bid for
example 30 minutes would you be willing
to take
one third of your time less oh 30 is it
depends on
it depends on what type of type of
player you are and how much you like
white clearly
but i think 30 i think those are the
bids that we might see something around
31
33 i think we'll see something in that
range
for both players yeah okay because
uh frankly it's nice to be white
too you know what you have to do all the
pressure's on you
uh to win that's it of course uh
draws are a little bit less likely so
you don't have to worry about that
result quite as much as you would have
to in a classical time game
right so some homework for the players
who are going to be
bidding and that's a tough thing they
don't know which color to prepare for
right because their opponent of course
can always outbid them right or under
bid them rather
and maurice you're quick uh well
actually maurice is getting set up with
uh irina crush who will talk about her
draw on this game and
tying for first in the women's
championship and likely a
three-way playoff tomorrow i guess
there's no handshake yet in the ana
zatanski game
no the one final trick in the position
uh would be that after knight h3 check
the one move you absolutely absolutely
cannot do is king after unless you want
to make enemies with irena
and cotton for the rest of your life ig5
would force a trader
speak to you again never speak to you
again uh but
after knight h3 check the uh simple and
correct king
uh to g3 and they're also playing king
verse kane
oh unbelievable round actually we saw
knight first king
and rook first king today in the women's
chess championship both players
literally wiping off the board
exhausting their chances
right and tomorrow we are going to see a
three-way play-off in the women's
championship and here we have
one of the players actually the
defending champion the only grandmaster
in the field
and she beat both of the players who are
going to be
in the playoffs oh drew versus talked up
right she drew his tattoo
and anna won burst hot death but she
lost first irena so irina has one and a
half and
on only has one and one okay so that's
why irena cross has the better tie
breaks and will be
seeded into the final and she's with
maurice ashley
indeed with grandmaster arena crush
after a tough game arena it looked like
you were winning to all rights and then
it evaporated
what are your thoughts about the game
yeah well it's uh it's a disappointing
game i think because certainly i felt
like my position around um
let's see where were we let's say around
here
was already preferable and um
okay in this moment it's kind of a
critical moment for some reason white
instead of
let's say developing a piece i was
expecting something like 92.
um i still preferred black you know
white went for the speculative move
knight f6 and i had seen that
um i really didn't think this move was
going to be dangerous at all for black
because
uh white has no pieces developed um so i
was feeling you know very happy here and
um so rook g8 seemed reasonable
um h7 yeah
what were you feeling well you think you
were going to win right now did you
think yeah i mean
i knew my position was just you know
winning i just i don't
know really what happened like this
moment this position that we went for
like
after ef5 i really just thought that
this would be
um this was not a teamable position for
whites with those pieces on a1 and c1
but somehow after king d2 i just
couldn't find
a way to win the game i mean yeah the
computer shows this computer line
just um yeah i guess that's quite good
c4 i should have played somewhere
well actually there's a miracle move
here for her that uh maybe
we could look at this position did you
look at the move rook g7 yeah of course
i mean but after queen f4
did you look at queen f5 well the last
f5 was also something i was looking for
this is the crazy lineup actually i
didn't see this bishop c8 right bishop
ca
this check and after this move yeah this
impossible move
queen eight six which just makes wow
that's nice i didn't of course
that's a very nice computer line yeah i
didn't see bishop c8 um
i mean i guess you have to see a lot of
geometrical motifs here
in order to win for black like um so it
wasn't
wasn't that easy um yeah because yeah
actually rook g7 queen f5 i just didn't
really see
exactly what i had here and it's not it
turns out bishop
is the only way to get yeah yeah i mean
queen e6 and the thing is you have to
register one rook h7 and queen f4
it's just not so easy to win for black i
mean of course black is better
but in the end you know i just wasn't
sure what to do maybe and uh my own king
is pretty weak there's not much to do
the knight is very strong and his a4
move is coming yeah like so you know
the computer just starting to show like
something retreating the [ __ ] which is
eventually what i wound up doing
um but yeah i mean that was
disappointing because the other position
was winning but i just didn't find find
the win
and um yeah the end game i'm sure yes
i know i there was one moment she could
have won at least one
uh like a little bit further yeah we did
look at we did look at those moves and
it looked like she had it there was a
little
g6 somewhere isn't there uh even at the
end she could have played d7 and you you
was would have been hard for you to
defend
so if we may let's not i know you want
to focus on the game you can do that
later uh what are your what are your
thoughts now
your tied your your closest rival
thankfully only drew
yeah and now you're in a three-way
play-off do you know the rules of the
playoff by the way
i well i heard uh jan and yasser talking
about the fact that i
would be seated into the into the final
match um
and that anna and tatev would be playing
first first match
so that sounds pretty good obviously
it's a lot harder i know to play uh two
matches
than one um but
yeah so you know well you know of course
i would have hoped to win the
championship at this
point and um but you got to take what
you get
you know i could also say i'm lucky
first of all that i didn't lose my
position and at the end
um also that anna didn't win you know so
um it's really it's really okay you know
i'm fine
playing a rapid tie break i've had uh a
number of experiences with that so
i know what it's about and um
just try to play better tomorrow how
have those rapids gone for you
generally quite decently yeah
and you know i just came back from
playing a rapid tournament in a haunted
mansion so i got
quite a lot of practice with rapid chess
um
and yeah i mean i'm actually i'm kind of
looking forward to it you know
why not try to win the championship in a
direct encounter with
your closest competitors excellent well
we wish you luck in tomorrow's games
will you be watching the game with
tatev and and anna oh probably not
no so how will you know the result
someone else
will know indeed well congratulations
and we look forward to watching you play
tomorrow
thank you maurice you're in a crush
five-time champion a chance to win her
sixth
title tomorrow after her main rivals
duke it out here at the u.s women's
championships guys
that's right anna zatonski and tatavar
abrahamian will be playing
the first match for the chance to play
the defending champion arena it kind of
works out perfectly doesn't it and
version okovian and um lenderman will be
playing for the chance to play
godakamsky so the defending champions
at the top of the heap will both of them
keep their titles
that is what we will find out tomorrow
but
what a round what a round of excitement
drama it had everything
arena winning honor winning arena losing
on a losing both draws wow
i can potential playoffs definite
playoffs
1 p.m tomorrow at central standard time
you know one interesting thing i'm not
sure who i like in tatev abrahamian's
match against anna zatonski because
despite the fact that anna of course
has a much higher rating and also great
experience
great experience abrahamian known for
her blitz skills in fact
one of our sponsors chess.com had what
they call
a death match tatev abrahamian came
on out on top versus on his atonski
but that's a blitz match that's five
minute three minute and one minute
yeah what's their individual heads up
score
who has the the better of those two
players between well i think in
in in classical games i'm pretty sure
that denonsky does but we can double
check that
uh but yeah the the blitz and the rapid
well i guess it's a rapid game
yeah but i still think that uh tatev
abrahamian
i don't think that she's a big underdog
in this match i think it's pretty close
to call
exactly and it will be about nerves too
nerves good play
and wow do they have the energy by the
way too
arena yeah that's a good question i mean
it it's it's a tall order and that's why
the rules are structured also because
there's a time constraint
right you don't want to play too round
two rapids followed by another play-off
only for the chance to play irena right
because they end up exhausting
themselves after three
or four uh battles in three hours
exactly and here we've got and here's
what tomorrow looks like jacobian and
lenderman
armageddon match winner plays godakamsky
and okay this one is reversed for the
ladies
uh zatonski and abrahamian armageddon
match to play against crosstalk
and uh irena liked i really liked the
playoff role did the math
a lot faster than me she was like yeah
one match is better than you
there you go i mean i point out that
there was a classic matchup between
these two players atonsky and uh
and abrahamian for the title was it
three years ago
or was it 2010 where they played a
vintage match
amazing match uh we were on the edges of
our seats calling that one
and eventually zotonsky proved
to be the victor in that one so not at
all clear that
abrahamian has any advantage against
this player
they are just going to be in a dog fight
tomorrow no question about it
i believe that was in 2011 and i think
that
tatava mohamian's approved a lot since
then
she's gotten her im title or she's
gotten all her i am norms and
a lot a lot more experience on her belt
so even in that match
she was very close to capturing the
title so i think it's really
very cool too close to call actually
okay really if i had to put my money on
and i'd probably go with anna but
it's very close i think i'll go with
anand for another reason
anna came to the event rusty she hadn't
by her own admission she had not played
enough and
now the tournament's over and you know
she's got her feeling back she knows how
the pieces move
again and so hopefully the rest is gone
and tomorrow is just going to be a great
match but
anna's in our studio we'll talk with her
too
tell us how she feels yeah we've got uh
ana sakonsky she's with maurice ashley
and uh she'll be playing a three-way
playoff tomorrow as well
in a topsy-turvy game wow
thanks guys i am with anna zatonski
after a terrific
battle where she managed to save the
game against katarina nimkova
ana that was war i mean you had to win
to go
win the championship and all of a sudden
it looked like you were in trouble maybe
and then you had to save yourself
what are your thoughts about the game
first of all i think i had a good
position now from opening and
i messed up something no just blunders
some tactics and
i thought strategically very good
position for me and
of course probably i should be happy to
save the game but in the end i was
playing for winners you could see this
in this end game
so it was some chances for me to win and
probably f3 it was
a good try to to make a draw for her
to draw the game and uh she she had to
find like a couple precise moves to draw
the game
so by the end i was a little bit unhappy
she played really well this
championships i mean her first time she
she had a solid
result but now what it's really about is
you
tatev and irina i mean this is this is
uh
the people that we expect at the end of
the championships it's happened now what
are your thoughts going into
tomorrow's matchup you have to play tate
first first of all with that match up
you played her in two you played her two
years ago for the championships
what do you think about that game okay
i'm still thinking about my previous
game which i just finished
i didn't know i had i have to play tatev
first and uh
i thought my uh burger is better but i'm
not sure maybe i'm wrong it's not a it's
not a burger tie break it's head to head
and
so okay i need to i need to read how
like we are playing which time control
and how many games oh so you don't know
the rules of the tiebreaker no but a
three-way
three-way tie break i don't know the
three-way tiebreak has used and i forgot
last year i didn't play tie bricks i'm
not sure
well you have to play an armageddon game
against tatev where you get on game well
yes right away right away where you bid
to see who gets black
and black has draw odds so that's the
situation
before you go and play arena
good what are your thoughts there
oh you know how many minutes it's like
between 45 minutes
you have to bid to see who has the lower
five plus five four minutes
no plus five anything no increment no no
increment no
wow it's brutal here at the championship
but i mean no the increments have to
move 60 or anything nothing not that we
know
nothing that we know it's american chess
here
yeah but this is new to two years old
ago was also american chess yeah
they really want to stick it to the
players this time really have a
challenge
what are your thoughts yeah probably i
should get our white and 45 minutes
okay so you've played tatev many times
before
in this tournament you played her in
fact yes and defeated her in the in the
tournament
what do you think about your chances
against a player like that
actually she's a very strong rapid hs
player so i think it's so it's it will
be not easier
so i think um
she she's really i played her in
on chess.com blitz match and i think she
defeated me
and uh i don't know i think it's her
chances are equal
uh if tata will beat me i think her
chances are probably higher versus arena
because she's really good in rapid chess
yeah
wow i'm oppressed yeah and especially
the person who is like last one to catch
leaders has such
certain indeed we saw what happened on
the men's side what do you think of god
komski's chances because he's in the
exact same situation he caught the two
men
and now he has to sit out and watch the
two of them play wow
okay then it's so i think he has good
chances to
win u.s championship again it's a little
bit strange way for him not like
last year indeed where he dominated so
what do you do to prepare for your last
round
uh probably i will uh get a good sleep
and rest because
uh like my level of energy is really low
so
i need to really rest and sleep and this
is probably about it
well we wish you the best in tomorrow's
match-ups and we'll be
calling your games you've been a
terrific fighter for these championships
so
thanks very much yeah thanks anna
zatonski
four-time champion looking to be a fifth
time champion but with some
severe obstacles in her way for the
women's championship
guys i'm so excited i can't wait for
tomorrow
i want something to happen really
exciting
she will take a break but we'll be back
tomorrow
fantastic yeah this is going to be very
exciting so a game 45
armageddon match no no
this is no delay so they're going to bid
on how much time they're willing to take
black and draw ads
right meanwhile whoever wins that match
will play against irena and gotta
respectively
and that match will be a two-game
rapid match so that's a game 25 with a
five second increment
and then if that match is split another
armageddon
so you guys do the math real quick our
maximum time that we're going to
be here tomorrow with you is about five
hours five and a half with bracelets
next that would be the maximum that's if
we go to the second arm again in one of
the games but you know what
that's pretty likely that at least one
of the games will end in the second
armageddon
because a 1-1 is a typical
score and they're so close and they're
so closely matched
the math for that is good there's more
ways to get one one
other course of course we got a final
thought from our ease
i love it i mean it means work for us
another day
but who doesn't want to call the u.s
championships
on the final day with all to play for
guaranteed winner you remember back in
the days yes
you used to do the gentlemanly ties at
the top
it was a three-way four-way tie at the
top of the championships
those days are gone and we will see a
winner tomorrow a single winner
come out of this championships and
rightfully call themselves
u.s champion and u.s women's champion so
i'm really looking forward to working
guys
how are we going to call the games we
got side side-by-side armageddon games
going on
and then the and then the championship
games it's going to be an incredible day
it is going to be wild you're definitely
not going to want to miss that what
about you y'all do you have a final
thought
prediction what's on your mind i would
actually like to ask our audience to
tell me what they think the winning bid
should be i would like to get a wide
sampling
of the bidding process
would you bid 30 minutes or less if
to take the black that would be the
question i would ask
would you be willing to give up 15
minutes and take the draw odds
you still didn't answer the question
final thoughts who's going to win
gotta arena chad and irina
that's so easy though hey you asked me i
i gotta i got the right to pick first so
i went with the defending champions
how about in the first match very very
very
hard i'm gonna go with a cobian
and i didn't like anna's level of
self-confidence but on the same hand
she's a little bit
uh self-deprecating she doesn't really
put herself out there
honestly i mean not in a bad way but
just kind of like got it trying to be
polite almost
yeah exactly the friend of hers right
but i think
anna i think anna's gonna we're gonna
see irina anna
once again these ladies have nine
championship rings between them
and they're they're gonna have a tent i
think i'm gonna go the opposite and take
alex and tatev
because alex has been playing pretty
quickly in this tournament i know rap is
a different animal
than a regular time control but i'm
going to take alex she's been
incompetent and aggressive and i'm going
to take tatev
because i know she practices a lot of
blitz and rapid
i just quickly guys i think that a lot
depends on who gets black
in the lenderman ocobian match up i
think if okobian gets black
i think he goes through he's so solid i
don't think he wants to have to win the
last game
that i think would be a challenge for
him if lenderman wins
the bid and gets black he's young he's
quick
he's confident i think that he'll be
thinking you're i'll be playing for the
win and i don't think you're going to
beat me
with that solid style and i think it's a
huge factor
who gets black in that armageddon game
if cobian gets it it's going to be real
hard to break
that solidity but if lenderman gets it
i think that lenderman goes through and
uh so who knows unless we know the bid
and then the other one the match-up
i've got to go with anna i mean she's
been shaky tatev hasn't been brilliant
herself
and i think that the time's not going to
matter she's just a great champion
all right well it's all going down
tomorrow this is the most dramatic us
chess championship i've ever seen
i am really grateful to be a part of it
and i just hope that all of you
have the time carved out tomorrow to
watch what is going to be
one of the most thrilling finales the us
championships and the us women's chess
championship
in chess history we'll be here one
o'clock central standard time 2 eastern
don't miss it it's only going to happen
once
you